[Music]
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do just pour
myself some water don't mind me
do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do hey everybody
boy I should get that water check out if
that color
refreshing hope everybody had a really
great weekend I had a very very busy one
but busy in a great way so yeah
Liz and I went to terrific on this past
weekend in Connecticut it was at Mohegan
Sun which is a casino I've never been in
a casino resort before I didn't set foot
on the casino floor but yeah it was a
really good trip and and I'm actually
gonna end up plugging the patreon
upfront because to be quite frank about
it if it wasn't for the patreon and the
level of support that I have through
that I would not have been able to do
this just the just the tickets the room
that was covered with patreon support
none of that what I happen otherwise
so I shout out to that but yeah this
pretty much got to be me recapping a con
weekend that's pretty much what this
will be and that's going to include a
bit of swag bragging with the stuff that
I ended up with and just sort of talking
about it but we'll ease into that a
little bit we'll let everybody settle
let people get in had to stop binging
season three of Gotham for this that's a
good season I still think season two is
the best one but honestly two three four
are solved with like tiny hiccups one is
not as insane as the show ultimately I'm
up getting which is kind of why hold on
I'm gonna shift this a little that's
better
um and one isn't as nuts as I like call
them to get season five is a mess but
that it's been gerbil stuff who's in the
pic on your necklace of okay yeah we
will start there so when I reviewed
stranger things season 3 I mentioned
tilt this down a little bit that yeah I
like season 3 a lot better and that
Steve was a big highlight he was one of
the the few things I really liked his
season too that was also the same for
Liz and both of us really loved Robin so
this is actually a gift from Liz and it
is it is Steve in his little sailor
outfit and she gave me this and she has
one of Robin in her little sailor outfit
so we have we're all cute and disgusting
and have two halves of the nautical
nerds which is what we choose to call
them doesn't exactly look like water I
think it's a thing it's just the color
on your monitor is making it look weird
it's definitely water I'm really
enjoying in st. Barbara and Saint
Barbara's the best Barbara as far as
Gotham goes not no question cringe yeah
I mean like it intentionally cringed
this is this is really cheesy but Liz
and I are honestly really cheesy or as
as one of her best friends I Karen is
fun of just say she just looks at it and
goes Oh barf we are very barf as a
couple he's Steven or Rob and was such
an awesome do it oh yeah they were great
any plans for an animation junkie review
infinity train what is infinity train
like that this is rare for somebody to
toss out something I mean that I
literally have never even heard of there
are things that I'm like I don't really
know what that is well
see the name before infinity trick fish
water of Mars review tomorrow really
looking forward to it that one I'll be
interested to see the reaction to that
one and I'll leave it at that
are you going to see the Joker movie
yeah probably I'm really curious for
ahead whether or not they're gonna be
able to pull this off
infinity train is a train that's like
infinite okay so infinity train is a
mini series off of Cartoon Network
that's basically about a girl who gets
on a multi-dimensional train and tries
to get back home huh I mean interesting
enough premise and heard of it
so I'd it's not exactly on my on my plan
docket do you see the final trailer for
Dark Crystal Age of resistance I saw one
from about a week ago if there was
another one since then that I haven't oh
thank you very much Peter I appreciate
that
off-topic sorry but any views on Doctor
Who events um not entirely sure what you
mean by that do you mean like when they
they did the screening of like end of
time in in select theaters is that kind
of what you're talking about or yeah I
Peter I'm gonna need you to clarify what
did you mean by that cuz I'm not
entirely sure I know it's surprising
okay so this is infinity train still
surprisingly dark at times with a
fantasy sci-fi horror series like over
the garden wall with a mix of adventure
time in okay now you've got my interest
because well I've never really got into
adventure time I love over the garden
wall it's amazing and I love that
miniseries and if you've never seen it
you should watch it
let's see I just started to watch the
boys will you be reviewing that I need
to ask that to add that to the list of
drink questions cuz that that's been
asked the last few times um I'm not
gonna rule it out but it's not a mine
it's not it's not my plan to like binge
through it and get a review out because
I'm not a huge Garth Ennis fan who wrote
the original comic that is based off of
so you know there's that um oh I guess
I'll mention the other the other bit
that I'm wearing that I actually bought
at the con which was these uh so I have
little sort of pixelated looking rainbow
hearts which are cute and fun sorry
chaos in Cardiff chaos it hurt alright
I'm not entirely sure what that is all
right we're gonna put this on pause for
a second I'm gonna see if a quick Google
search is gonna clue me in to what is
being asked of me here
that's Incarnate I'm getting information
about a traffic jam I'm very lost right
now Peter say you saved me you don't
have like at this point I'll keep an eye
out for you you don't have to hit me up
with a super chat ever talk to me if you
want to I won't stop you but you don't
have to move a super childhood every
time because I don't want you to think
I'm trying to milk more out of you in
order to answer your question I want to
answer your question just not I'm not
following I'm very lost right now
um you've got a selfie with Behrman so
mb so yeah okay yeah let me um let me
just sort of burn through real quick
what the weekend was like so um chipping
all fired etc oh I heard that like
circulated but like it's last I knew it
was not accurate that is that is the
most current information that I have
that that was inaccurate so no I have no
thoughts on it because I don't discuss
rumours and even if it hadn't been
discounted by the BBC my stance would
still be I'm not gonna talk about it
because until it's official like it it's
a it's a use of my brain space that I
don't really care for you know just and
I don't even mean like I'm not trying to
belittle anyone who likes to talk about
rumours and shoot that stuff but it's
just like I don't want to clutter up my
head with a whole thought train on
something that's a huge maybe so I I'm
not really gonna go there but okay
anyway so a terrific on what uh the
three days looked like it was about a
four-hour drive from from where I lived
down to down to Connecticut for this we
so listen I got there we actually drove
in our initial cosplays we did cosplay
all three days different cosplay each
day for both of us
day one I was rockin my thirteenth
doctor's she was a super girl so we got
there checked into the hotel and hit the
the con floor first day Friday was I
mean it was it was pretty big but it
fairly subdued and I really came to
appreciate that the next days where it
was very crowded but there were a couple
of panels we went to that first day no
there was no it was just one panel we
went to that first day we went to a
diversity in cosplay panel which had on
it
Sharon Rose spectra and night mage who
are all cosplayers and talked about you
know what what they do and and their
thoughts on cosplay and and the topic of
like who can do what came up and they
had a really interesting perspective
especially when it comes to to cosplay
specifically which is that if you love a
character you can cosplay that character
the one hard rule they set out is don't
artificially darken your skin but and I
don't want to say that like what I'm
relaying what was said on the panel so I
don't want anyone to take this as like a
all call the cosplay community is cool
with this because they may not be but
certainly the people on the panel sort
of put out there like one of them I
think was spectra said he had a he had a
friend who is white who did a storm
cosplay that he really loved and it was
okay because she didn't darken her skin
because you're you're always going for
something that is evocative of character
anyway most cosplayers especially if
you're doing it for fun aren't going for
complete page to screen accuracy and
even if you are with the costume that
doesn't mean that you have to do things
like darken your skin which people
should not have to have explain to them
why they shouldn't do that but it was it
was a really interesting talk and a
conversation and all three of them were
great cosplayers I saw them all three
days the day that we were there
Sharon Rose was in Captain Marvel
spectra was doing fin from Star Wars and
the first day night mage was The Living
Tribunal his stuff was crazy so he was
The Living Tribunal and then the second
day he was he was like Ultimate Universe
MCU
um Nick Fury but costumed like like he
was 90s David Hasselhoff version Nick
Fury um and then the third day he did
Batman animated series version of to
face which was amazing and I saw the
other one I saw spectra in was I saw him
do Frozone and Sharon Rose also did a
beetlejuice which is really good
I'm gonna back up thank you very much
tandems hey would you review something
more adult or keep strictly
family-friendly love you I am perfectly
willing to review adult stuff I mean
some of the stuff that I like I'm
Jonathan thank him like the most
quote-unquote adult thing ever I mean
like some of the stuff I reviewed is not
for you like I reviewed annihilation I
consider that to be a very adult movie
so I certainly have no I would have no
issues doing reviews of stuff intended
for you know not meant for young people
at all most of what I talk about is
family entertainment but that's just
because you know that's just the target
audience is going for now that said even
if I talk about something that's more
adult I'm probably still going to talk
about it and in a family-friendly way
and the actual video I make will still
be a family-friendly video but you know
I can talk about you know more mature
themes films what-have-you
without having to have the actual video
end up being not family-friendly as a
result possibly depends on what the
review is for I don't want people to
think that that's a challenge in like
then somebody Commission's me like a
like a porn parody or something I don't
know I might I might a cook my own goose
ah altering carbon is not kid-friendly
either no no it is not some of the mug
is a bit adult adult water haha
did you hear that the showrunner of Game
of Thrones got a deal with Netflix for
five years any thoughts is that official
or is that rumored cuz last I knew the
two of them the two showrunners were
working
on Star Wars so that's new to me
do you think awesome Gotham season 5
would have worked better if it was 21
episodes and the second half included
The Killing Joke as a plotline no to The
Killing Joke The Killing Joke is a
product of its time and needs to be left
there I I'm done seeing anyone trying to
adapt The Killing Joke at all to be
honest wouldn't have been better if it
was 21 episodes possibly cuz we would
have given that stuff room to breathe
but I still feel that even if season 5
was longer the story that they did was
not the story to do for the final season
the whole entire thing with with how it
involved Bane and everything else it was
not there was not the story line to go
out on now if they had more time it
would have space stuff out and like
things like the ventriloquist which
ended up being one episode will probably
would have been 2 or 3 which is what it
needed to be so it would have been
better I still would have had a lot of
my same complaints though I think even
if it had been full 20 full 21 episode
season oh thank you Meg very much what
are your thoughts on static cling
Rocko's Modern Life special um I haven't
watched it yet enough people have
brought to my attention the lgbtq+ a
representation angle of it I don't know
a lot of the details I just know it's in
there and that it is prominent enough
that I do want to find the time to see
it whether or not I'll make a video out
of it after I have seen it I don't know
flip a coin on that at 50/50 depends on
what my thoughts are after I have seen
the thing but certainly after I've seen
it I'll definitely be willing to talk
about on the livestream if nothing else
um but as of right now I don't know
where not when I'll get to that I'm
right now I am in the middle of re
watching Torchwood children of Earth
which Oh God I it's been a long time
since I saw it and last time I saw it I
didn't have my own kid yet so yeah
that's uh that's a trial
it's like it
it's still good and I'll have my full
thoughts out when the review goes up but
man huh I think I know I haven't seen
Miracle Day yet Jamie I'm like I've been
meaning to but I heard enough mix things
about it's never been a priority and I
really do like children of earth I think
it's really well done but I tell you a
man I think it is quite possibly the
darkest thing ever made within the
Doctor Who universe like the only thing
that would even come close to touching
it would be maybe turn left but I I
don't think it even comes close just
given that as darkness turn left get it
still ended pretty decently and that's
one episode chosen of Earth is five so
yeah it's uh uh it's heavy it's very
heavy and like and like in a black
mirror way in a way that like eats up
your brain space and you're like oh why
can't I stop thinking about this thing I
want to stop thinking about it not
because it's bad but because like I need
to think about something I need to think
about rainbows and puppies is something
else children of Earth it hurts but you
can't stop watching it yeah yeah thanks
for starting the Harry Potter review so
soon oh yeah absolutely Lucy I I'm
excited to do them I don't think I
actually mentioned it in the review I
actually got commissioned to do these
movies and like a revisit to these was
always something that I kind of figured
in the back of my head I'd get to
eventually but I never had you know a
timeline planned but once I got I got
commissioned to revisit these through
the patreon Hey plug it again um I I got
very excited to go back and rewatch
these so it's it's a blast already let's
see children birth painting life it's a
ninja's cauldron of despair death death
and more pain
know that no you you're also missing
anxiety and painful consequences and
horrible choices and yeah it's it's so
much more than death and pain and that's
why sticks with you because I mean it's
just death and pain you know that may be
dark but you move on from it something
that is death and pain and anxiety and
oh my god what would I do in that
situation because people are making
choices that you know that drive the
story that's what makes it like ah man
water will ease the pain so oh can we
talk about Barrowman okay yes so like
moving forward because I more or less
cover day one now so day two at terrific
on um I a couple things related to John
Barrowman actually let me backtrack I
had gotten tickets for and there was
supposed to be a cabaret that he was
going to host on Friday night that got I
had tickets for that that got cancelled
um because his voice wasn't up to it he
had like completely lost his voice but
he wasn't in he wasn't in in you know
belting singing for an hour plus
condition so that got cancelled but he
still appeared and so on Saturday he he
actually had like like a whole photo op
thing that I didn't do cuz like you
needed to buy the tickets in advance to
do that and I missed the window but I
did catch him out of booth and I got
selfies with him and on that so that was
day two and Liz and I went all all Harry
Potter for this one so I have my
slithering gear on and she was gone up
like Luna Lovegood complete with spectra
specs and the lying on her head uh she
she got stopped a bit in that outfit um
she was adorable and that so I was in my
slithering gear
and young pain - you know I'm waiting in
line I'm paying his assistant to be able
to get the selfies with him excuse me
and his assistants said hey ask him what
his Hogwarts houses so I went up to him
and I told him how much I love his work
and I really appreciated what he brought
especially to Doctor Who and then I
asked him what his Hogwarts houses and
what he said was that he has his own
special house that is separate from all
the others the the main room is down is
kind of hidden near the whomping willow
and it's Gaffin door he claims to have a
crest like a custom crest made for and I
couldn't he didn't have anything like
that on him and I couldn't like Google
image search came up negative on me um
but yes gaff and door were all are
welcome that made me smile a lot and so
that oh sorry hand I accidentally ran
into David Gareth Lloyd in an elevator
and convention I almost cried it was
awesome
that's adorable so then later that day
we went losing I went to two panels that
day we went to thing called Doctor Who
101 which was all a I wasn't sure what
it was gonna be ended up ultimately
being more for her benefit cuz it was
kind of a quick and dirty rundown of
sort of the history of the show but it
was a lot of stuff she didn't know
pretty much all of it I did and then
after that John Barrowman basically the
host like normally when you get uh
celebrity out of like a panel that is
about them you know they're sitting
behind behind a table they got the mites
there's the facilitator sitting next to
them you know prompting them with you
know questions to lead them down a
certain path no they cleared off the
stage and just handed John Barrowman a
mic and let him go and he stepped up
initially in the Captain Jack overcoat
which he then shed to reveal in people
may have seen pictures of these his
Swarovski crystal and or completely
blinged up TARDIS dress and and these
these Swarovski crystal Leyden high
heels and he did a little spin and a
twirl and he just rocked the stage for I
don't even know how long I think they
actually let him go long it was like an
hour and a half and and he he and he
just shared stories you know sort of
warming up and you know just talking
about like one of the airline flights to
one of the recent cons he'd been to or
things like that but then he would start
taking questions and every question
would basically launch him into whatever
next story was gonna tell so you know he
would get a question about working on
arrow and he would tell about how he
liked to mess with Stephen Amell and he
got a question about making out with
James Marsters for Torchwood series two
and he got to share a story about how
that came about shooting that scene and
it was it was just wonderful I act this
is embarrassing
so huh I got to ask what you selected me
to get to ask my question and what I
asked him was is what were because I
know he really loves musical theater
what were some roles in musical theater
that he hasn't done yet that he would
really like to and I only remember bits
and pieces of his answer because I was
standing there going oh my god he's
looking and talking directly at me don't
look like an idiot so like I didn't
register probably about half of what he
said in response to that which is uh
which is a little embarrassing
I've kissed James Marsters he's a good
kisser really tandems I'm
I'm envious and curious but yeah that
was that was a lot of like my cheeks
hurt I laughed so much and like he's
he's very cheeky so like one of the
first things he said cuz he saw how
young some of the people in the crowd
were it's like oh you look like you're
you're about 12 where are your parents
if they brought you here it's their own
fault because I'm not effin censoring
myself and he didn't oh it was very very
funny don't look like an idiot grids and
nods the whole time yeah yeah that was
that was pretty much it
do you look to watch things because
actors from Doctor Who are in them I try
and watch all of Matt Smith stuff I
don't really I like had a brief phase of
that kind of thing like when I was in
college so like after Lord of the Rings
came out I was like really attentive to
anything the main cast in that series
did but then I realized within about a
year is like I'm landing on a lot of
stuff that I don't really care about and
didn't enjoy and so I went back to my
default of figure out if this is a story
you have any interest in and go from
there and not just be like oh I'll see
everything from this act no I don't do
that anymore so yeah John John Barrowman
was that was that was a good time
that was a lot of fun yeah and so that
was the two panels we did that day see
I'm so excited to be here for the first
time I love this channel so much ah
Thank You Brittany glad to have you here
oh and here was the fun that I had there
were two instances one on the second day
and one on the third day where I got
recognized and somebody came up to me
and said hey I'd get an equivalent of
hey like your channel or actually the
first time it was I I just wanted to let
you know I'm
of the council and that was actually
after the John Barrowman panel John
Barrowman panel and he came over me
while I'm gathering my stuff up and he
he said the he he recognized me because
he heard my voice when I was asking my
question it was like wait is that so
that was cool and then just on the floor
last day I I got I got recognized by
somebody else so that was uh that was
pretty cool uh Thank You Kaylee what's
your favorite musical theater
performance um do you mean like to watch
or to do cuz I've done musical theater
um not a lot of huge lead roles that are
worth bragging about
um but okay so um I mean it's it's hard
to stay so like I think what I've been
most bowled over by my see and I am
gonna stick to theater I'm not gonna
talk about a musical film um I I saw I
saw wicked on Broadway and the the woman
who was playing Elphaba cuz it wasn't it
wasn't a big name there was nobody big
because oh god what idina menzel had had
moved on from part by then um I don't
know what her name was but she was
actually she was actually an understudy
which was something that that my
daughter's mother and I cuz we were
still together then we know we sort of
noted because during the curtain calls
she had the hugest grin on her face like
she could not believe she got to do it
in front of an audience and she was
phenomenal
she was great I mean I like that show
anyway but it does really kind of live
or die on the performance of Elphaba and
she was amazing I also could see
hairspray on Broadway Hey and George
went norm from Cheers
play Edna the mother the one play by
John Travolta in the and the musical
film version that was really good too
I look like an idiom for Anna van that
nice Stewart head when I met him oh my
god
I think most of us probably look like
idiots when we meet these people this is
the first time I've ever watched a live
video was live well welcome thanks for
telling your stories you look beautiful
today oh thank you very much ah so yes
yes Carolyn I I did you have every right
to be green with jealousy cuz because
George when does that know was was great
yep
I will always remember he had this one
line where he liked that where the
character I had no one basically wants
to get in a fight and get stopped and
the the line is Tracy hold Mommy's
waffles and the way he just delivered it
was Tracy hold Mommy's waffles cuz he
cuz he'd been doing a pitched up voice
for the entire run of the show up to
that point let me just let it drop like
that it was oh that was great
am i able to do a one-time payment on
patreon sorry for spelling um sort of
the wait patreon the way the patreon is
set up is that it is set up as a monthly
so if you wanted to do it as one time um
you could come in on a tear of the
patreon and they you and get the
benefits of whatever you get for a month
and be sure that you cancel your you
cancel it after it's gone through so
that it doesn't recur every month
alternately I've started putting in the
description also linked to my paypal
which basically functions as a tip jar
where if you want to do a one-time
support thing you can do it through
PayPal and not have to worry about
having to cancel a membership that said
doing it that way is not going to incur
any of the patreon benefits so if you
wanted to get any of those if you wanted
to get the sign business card or any of
the the higher-grade
benefits of the higher tiers of the
patreon you would need to do it through
that cuz I can't keep track of doing
stuff is a one-time through PayPal on
top of to be on top of the patreon I
just won't be able to do it
I remembered why I got up did you see
the original hair spray movie I saw
about half of it John Waters as a
filmmaker is is very odd he's one of
those people who like I don't really
like his movies but I want to like sit
down and have a drink with him and just
just shoot the breeze for like four
hours um but I don't really love his
movies all that much I like him as a
person I think he's very he's
fascinating did you watch the Anastasia
animation the the Don Bluth yeah that's
that that's an odd Beast that thing
because it is it is so transparently
obvious that he's trying to do his spin
of of Disney Princess with that story
and it's a weird fit for him it's pretty
good um honestly Rasputin needs to be
removed from that movie that entire
thing and it needs to just be the story
straight without that entire element but
it's it's decent it's not bad are you
excited for the new Witcher series on
Netflix the books are amazing I I don't
know I saw the trailer and it didn't
really grab me very much and that's
probably one where I'll probably either
shoot the breeze yeah look look Ben
that's the that's the PG version of what
I what my instinct was to say um so
anyway um with something like The
Witcher I'll probably either go in and
give it like two or three episodes and
then decide from there or a look at
reviews and see what the general trend
is and go from there I don't um I don't
bother with reviews for anything that I
know for certain I'm gonna see no matter
what but if I'm on the fence about
whether or not I'm gonna sync the time
to something especially if it's a series
I I will I will wait for reviews a
little bit what do you suppose will lead
to the downfall of streaming services
well they're they're subdividing where I
now so like it's it's funny what's going
on with streaming services right now is
basically what happened with television
between 2530 years ago
so initially television was the
broadcast networks and they were
monoliths NBC CBS CBS ABC later on Fox
and then you know when cable started out
it was a handful of like again kind of
monolithic channels the Disney Channel
Nickelodeon HBO some premium some not
but they were this one specific thing
but then cable show started subdividing
and getting more and more and more more
and more specifically you got a flood of
sub yet fifty million has PN's and you
had the sci-fi channel and you had TBS
and TNT and FX and channels that were
redesigned specifically to do one thing
and channels that just seemed to change
what they were doing every other day and
the it got very cluttered and that was
kind of the environment in which
something like Netflix and streaming in
the first place was able to swoop in and
be oh we get to be the alternative to
all that cluttered crap but now
streaming is turning into the same
cluttered crap that it used to be the
alternative to so we were hitting a time
in which you know all of the olivine
biggest studios and networks are
realizing hey we don't have to license
our stuff to Netflix we can run our own
service and under nor under under a
truly even playing field a bunch of
these wouldn't last more than a year you
know things like Apple TV and the CBS
one and you know a whole bunch of these
we just would just crash but the problem
is because the parent companies are
these huge monolithic corporations you
know Disney Plus Warner Brothers Time
Warp that's
huge Amazon with Amazon Prime TV or
whatever they they can afford to just
keep plugging away at it simply so that
they are not giving their competition
the rights to it because that's the
thing with something like Disney
launching their own streaming services
it's not just a question of whether or
not the streaming service is profitable
even if it isn't or if it's right on the
edge if they decide to end it and start
licensing stuff back to say Netflix
that's gonna be seeing scene as them
bolstering a competition company so
because of the weird just sort of
corporate politics that go on III don't
see all I see is is streaming
subdividing into more and more and more
individual things and if like it won't
you won't get to them supporting it
won't get to the point where you
actually have to subscribe to every
individual show you want but it'll start
to feel like that say yeah I'm not I'm
not thrilled with where things are
headed streaming service wise I haven't
owned a TV in more than two in over 20
years that power to you what's going on
with the new Doctor Who series I have no
idea there's rumors of a lot of stuff
that's being debunked so far as I know
right now nothing why did you stop using
the TARDIS green screen and the TARDIS
sweater for your Doctor Who videos well
the reason I stopped using the sweater
was I got other gear to wear you know
for the reviews of like the overdue who
reviews I and I told cosplay of doctors
I'm reviewing and when I do classic I
have the scarf which I like better I
still have that sweater I didn't get rid
of it I got rid of the green screen cuz
it was a huge pain in my ass between
where it's set up not being not having
particularly great acoustics and it
being a pain in the butt to work with
and I mean
I I should at least give a trial on the
on the editing software I have now
because I have actually never tried
using the green screen effect on my
current editing software I just know
that on my old editing software it kind
of looks like ass um maybe it would work
better now and if if I determine that
maybe I'll figure out something to do
with it but it's just a big pain it's a
really big pain in the butt but ok
generation productions I I said earlier
that I I don't I don't I don't expose it
to much on rumors because I don't want
to sink the time and just something that
may or may not be true I'd rather wait
for official word and then talk about
that because like there are a lot of
channels out there that every time a
rumor if it's spicy enough will you know
release a video and a hot take and their
thoughts on that and but those kinds of
channels you look at them even months
down the line and you see they've got
video after video after video devoted to
nonsense stuff that wasn't even real and
that and I'm not necessarily knocking
them maybe they are ok with that I'm not
I like to look at my back catalogue of
stuff and go yeah there's still a reason
to look at that and or it's not
embarrassing now that I spend so much
time talking about this thing that
wasn't even real that would be
embarrassing to me
I don't mean like professionally like on
a personal level that would annoy me so
that's a big part of why I don't I don't
do that have you ever been to Wisconsin
I am NOT there are i out of the 50
states hang on let me see if I can
figure this out cuz i if I'm not
counting ones that I just drove through
and like once I actually stopped and did
things in let me thank you
fifteen I think no sixteen sixteen
states
I've been to and done something in
seventeen there we go so like not a high
percentage there's a lot of states I
have never been to a lot of major cities
I've never been to as well are you
planning on going to the Netherlands uh
no it's not on my docket can you name
them in alphabetical order
haha Oh what is on your nut you're yeah
cuz okay I'll show it again briefly it's
Steve from season three of stranger
things I mentioned that earlier you're
from Vermont right are you totally sick
of fish
I'm actually not sick of fish I'm just
sick of people not from Vermont asking
me in some way about fish cuz I I just
don't care I never have what might you
use for videos I use a now it's
downstairs right now it's a video mic
from Road I think is how you pronounce
it I I actually when I first started I
spent more money on the mic than I did
on the camera I mean the camera I have
now not what I'm using right now right
now I'm using my phone but the camera
shoot video on now um you know I got
earlier this year and spent a bit on but
the initial camera I started the channel
with I spent more money on the mic than
I did the camera because I knew I
learned I was in a I was in an
independent film that never got released
when I was in New York and I remember
going to the cast screaming and I
couldn't make out about half the
dialogue because he did a bunch of
location shooting and he you know it was
low-budget with mediocre mics and I
don't know if he ever had the money to
go in and do ADR and and dubbing I was
never brought in if he ever did it again
I doubt it thing never got a release but
that sort of taught me immediately like
gonna be way more forgiving if they know
you're working with not a lot of money
people are gonna be way more forgiving
of mediocre video then they will be of
mediocre audio cuz if people can't hear
what's going on it doesn't matter how
good it looks so even though this is a
visual medium I actually think if you're
gonna get into something like youtuber
or even short film or whatever you need
it's more important to have really good
audio equipment than it is that really
good video equipment there's a new
animated series on coming to Amazon
Prime next month it's called undone and
its creators are some of the producers
of Bojack horseman see I still haven't
um I still haven't seen Bojack horseman
I'm not I'm not eager to get that
depressed I gotta say that your videos
on LGBT topics are always really great
and some of them are really nice for me
to hear as a person with my community
Thank You Kristen that's always great to
hear I I I'm really proud of those
videos I always am favorite Doctor Who
episode to watch for fun or comfort okay
if we're doing fun um huh
like it's it's not the fluffiest in the
world it's got its heavy moments but
like first thing is coming to my mind is
Amy's choice was terrific on worth the
cost yes it was I think well I mean well
next year I'm going to Gallifrey one I
don't know if I'll do another con later
in the year besides that it kind of
depends on what my financials are like I
think I'd look at other possibilities
beyond terrific on but if I absolutely
loved going it was it was great
I am I agree with video equipment I'm a
high schooler and I plan to stay at a
YouTube channel one day and I was
something out of audio equipment is my
worst block yeah like that you can have
a nicest-looking video in the world but
if it sounds Scratchy
or indecipherable or just like garbage
nobody's gonna watch us
actually if like you talking my stuff as
the point of the thing is it fair to say
that a bad but fun story is better than
a well written and performed but boring
story more often than not yes I would
say depends on why it's boring and the
reason I put that Asterix is there are
some things that it's there's an
artistic reason for it to be boring and
there's other times it's boring just
because it's not interesting so but for
the most part I would say yes I would
rather watch something with a lot of
flaws that's fun than something that is
at a high technical level and doesn't
have a lot of things for me to pick
apart but is dull if you could have
anyone who has played the doctor to play
the master and vice versa who would it
be
oh okay I'd be up for seeing Michelle
Gomez play the Matt I'd play the doctor
and I mean Peter Capaldi would be a good
master actually Tom Baker like now like
right now Tom Baker as the master I kind
of want to see that now never had that
thought before now I want okay I have
some other stuff to show off that I came
away with from terrific on so before I
forget when we get too much further into
this what time is it oh yeah we're
getting out so as has become a bit of a
tradition Liz got me a Lego figure of a
cosplay so I now have Lego figures of
Wonder Woman of poison ivy and now 13th
Doctor all bought for me by Liz at cons
because I have done those cosplays at
said cons so that's that's really nice I
got so I mentioned one of the cosplayers
Sharon Rose and she also was selling
stuff
specifically she was selling hair hair
flowers that she made one of which I
picked up which is this so that is a
that is a Slytherin hair flower it's in
some of some of the pictures I took oh I
didn't finish recapping okay last day
there were a couple things also I got a
lot a look at the at the discord so last
day we did two panels I went to well I
did we did a panel we caught the end of
the costume contest so the panel that we
went to on Sunday was was Chris
Claremont now if you don't know that
name Chris Claremont is basically the
reason anybody cares about x-men because
the x-men may have been created by Stan
Lee in the 60s but that didn't last very
long and all the stuff that we now think
of as being ingrained in and
fundamentals to the x-men ie a lot of
the social implications a lot of the
applicability to mine or base of any
kind that came about because of how
Chris Claremont wrote the x-men I mean
he wrote the x-men in the 70s of the 80s
into the start of the 90s and he's done
a lot of writing aside from that but
that's what he's best known for and
that's mostly what he talked about um he
also like did a lot of work with the
character of Carol Danvers back when she
was MS Marvel as opposed to cap tomorrow
so it was before that but that was great
cuz he's he's this he's this crotchety
old guy who doesn't have a reason to not
just say what he's thinking and he it
was he's not above throwing a bit of
shade at things like DC both the comics
and the movies and he actually brought
up okay two things both John Barrowman
and Chris Claremont sort of touched on
Game of Thrones somebody actually asked
John Barrowman what he thought about the
last season of game
Thrones when he spoke with his words he
was fairly diplomatic however before he
spoke with his words he just throw up
his middle finger hahahaha so I think
that was his more insensitive thoughts
on it Chris Claremont actually said some
very nice things about it but restricted
specifically to characters like Arya and
Sansa because he felt that the journey
those characters went through was not
dissimilar to how he tried to handle
when he when he wrote the x-men and
aside from just being a a really cool
talk and and getting a bit of inside
baseball and sort of and like him
talking about working with Stan like
because this is back when Stan was
editor-in-chief and there weren't like
individual editors for different brands
because you know later on there be an
x-men editor and a spider-man editor and
a cosmic editor but like just it was
Stan running the whole thing and not
writing comics anymore and what what
Chris Claremont said was Stan Lee had
three rules there were three things that
he wanted from you have the story you
wrote be good have it be delivered on
time
and don't be a pain in his ass and as
long as you did two out of those three
you'd keep your job ideally you do all
three but if you did any two you would
continue to work there which was very
cool what would be the worst Multi
doctor story in terms of which three
doctors would literally not get along
and spend the whole story arguing oh boy
who would who would be nonstop arguing
[Music]
six eight and twelve they'd be at each
other's throats there's a film from 1999
called American movie was filmed in my
home state of Wisconsin James Rolfe has
stated multiple times I just one of his
favorite movies of all time it's not the
documentary um that you're talking about
there Conner because I haven't seen it
but if that's what it is I've heard
about it
[Music]
but yeah yeah yeah current chris chris
claremont was a lot but and actually one
of the things that i really loved was
the and that was a more traditional one
would you know the table and then
somebody kind of prompting him with
questions to keep the to keep the
conversation going and the guy kept
asking about you know the injections of
the of the social issues into x-men any
he kept it was like he was trying to get
chris claremont to say oh yeah I went in
intentionally wanting to write about
that sort of thing and Chris Klem I just
didn't bite he just went down and what
came out of what he said was that he and
he never said outright what I'm about to
say but what he said very much point to
this and I'm gonna use some of his exact
words which was that he never went in
with the intention of addressing social
issues but because of these characters
and their very nature of their powers
and the fact that people were afraid of
them and like a whole bunch of them
weren't even American we're technically
illegal aliens um as long as he wrote
those characters honestly and were true
to the characters and honored them in
the journeys they were going through and
what would worry and concern them then
that stuff just happened he didn't have
to go out of his way to inject social
issues into it just treating the
characters honestly meant that the
social issues just came up and I thought
that was amazing I thought that was that
was a that was a really cool sort of bit
of insight and like and the most common
thing that he said by far talking about
writing for xmin was it was fun I had
fun we did it cuz it was fun and yeah I
really liked him a lot
okay got a few other things to show you
all right this was on the last day I
bought this and this is not comics
related but for what it is it was so
cheap that I'm like I
would feel very dumb if I didn't get
this this was $25 and I don't doubt that
that's probably about what it's worth in
reality in terms of the value of these
crystals and whatever but like this is
actual metal you know the backing and
everything it's not a single piece it
has some bend to it because there's
joints on it and I've seen equivalent
pieces like this on Etsy and whatnot and
they don't go for $25
so I don't know when I'll use this
probably hosting shows more than
anything but like I'd stared at it for
all three days last day I'm like I need
to get that so it was that um there were
a few things that I got that I'm
actually not gonna show cuz there are
actually gifts for other people um but
that was another cool thing that listen
I got to do who sort of consult with
each other hey do you think this person
would like that no yeah they really like
that and it's it's it's very fun to shop
for other people sometimes I like
especially something like a con where
you spot something like oh that would be
perfect for this person and then if it's
not too expensive you do it please wear
that in the video oh if I can think of
one where it's even vaguely appropriate
I will I don't think I have the nerve to
just wear it apropos of nothing though
uh my friend once got me a Tribble at a
con is it just the water I did the
jewelry glow when you held it up and I
think you had two heads
um Ben III think you might want to slow
down on your hydration if you could own
any prop from any movie or TV show what
would it be
um okay if we're talking original prop
the golden idol head from Indiana Jones
and the Raiders of the Lost Ark we're
talking recreation I don't know probably
some ridiculous piece of weaponry or
maybe only slightly ridiculous like I'd
really love uh I've seen someone they're
crazy expensive like I'd really love a
recreation of the AB Dekkers gun from
Blade Runner do you think the Cybermen
would have worked better in the series
one finale also if there's anything you
change about that finale what would it
be I my issues with the series one
finale um only have to do with the first
half but I don't like bad wolf
I think parting of the ways is good very
good even um but my issues are all with
bad wolf it's all the set up but it said
what where it's actually going when it
gets there it's fine so no I wouldn't I
wouldn't have put the Cybermen there and
I wouldn't really want to change that I
would just want to alter the set up and
drop all the stupid friggin game show
and reality TV spoofs hey I liked Missy
as a character but I took issue with her
not wanting power she wanted to turn the
doctor when wanting power is kind of a
masters whole point well it depends on
which master you're talking about
because different masters have had
different operating principles there is
a desire to control and what you could
argue is that in the arc in the
incarnation of Missy that desire to
control has narrowed down to the doctor
himself as opposed to expanding out to
wanting to try and control the whole
universe because that is the master that
at its core is the Masters gig wanting
to have control whether that be over
other species whether it be over the
entire universe whether it be over the
fact that he should be dead that he's
expense the whole point of the crispy
master is that he should he should have
died he should be gone but he is
desperately holding on because he will
not let go of that control and so I I
can by miss
focusing that need to control and
narrowing that to just targeting the
doctor so for me that that works I do
get what you're saying but that's how I
kind of square that circle it's worth
mentioning that Scarface is coming to 4k
on October I've never seen Scarface I
don't know like I've seen bits and
pieces and I know enough about it but
like that's one of the ones I have not
seen it who's your favorite Harry Potter
Death Eater what was a favorite Death
Eater I don't know I suppose
Lucius by default because ask not a
surprise oh god Jason Isaacs um but
that's a weird question to me for some
reason
are you in favor or opposed to the
retcon and Dave the doctor Oh which one
um I'm assuming you mean the fact that
Gallifrey didn't actually fall um I'm
okay with it or at least I I was last
time I saw the thing I haven't seen in a
while we'll see when I get up to the
rewatch if my feelings have changed my
issue with that well no it wasn't even
really an issue because the sort of the
way I was okay with it where my issue
would have been is the idea that I I
liked
Gallifrey being gone and the idea of it
kind of being saved was kind but then it
was like it what it was saved but it was
lost so instead of being blown up it's
now it's somewhere but the darker can't
find it and he's still alone and I was
okay with that that was a shift that was
okay with I do think that Moffat
resolved that too quickly because I
think the doctor should have just been
searching for Gallifrey for it
definitely as far as I'm concerned so
like what came after I have more issues
but Dave the doctor I'm okay with would
that thoughts on the story of the sea
devil
that was great that's that I think see
Devils is the best story to get to watch
Roger Delgado's master do his thing he's
good in other episodes as well but
sometimes he's good in episodes that are
great like I I know I I'm an exception
here I really don't like the clause of
access all that much but he's really
good in his scenes in it see Devils is
the one I recommend because not only is
he good but the story overall is good as
well what are your favorite perche
stories and can you give a brief mini
review of them of geez I mean my my
favorite see Devils what she just said
the other one that I really like with
virtually is time warrior I've still got
a lot of gaps with my Pertwee including
major ones like I sell the scene green
death just cuz that one's all that one's
really long um so I've still got some
major ones to hit that I haven't yet
okay so let me get back to a swag bag so
my primary addiction at cons is art
commissions and I did for this time so
let's see okay so I've got one here from
Heather Farrington there's actually a
bunch here in this portfolio but the one
I got this year was that one and that is
Captain Marvel as a fairy
um that's something I started doing I'm
started getting some superheroes done as
fairies I have Wonder Woman someone
she's not on the portfolio she's over
there I need to put her in
but Heather Farrington is actually she
actually was the very first stars I ever
commissioned a couple years ago at
Vermont comic-con with that squirrel
girl that was the very first Commission
I ever got and I have I've commissioned
her every time I've seen her attic on
sense I think maybe with one exception I
didn't at the time I wasn't I was just
staying long enough so there was that I
got
grab this because this is actually in
its own sleeve I got a little sort of
trading card size mystique artist by the
name of Ryan Santos did that one and
then I think I'm cold on that felt
crooked that's gonna bug me if I don't
fix it yeah this makes for good watching
[Music]
then I think this is this is my favorite
Commission of the conda's from Jamie
boot arrow and this is I Skorpio from
the new Shira and I love this I love
this piece and this was this was
actually that for for a watercolor
this was quite affordable that's kind of
what I'm always on the lookout for
because and it's why I don't get
commissions from the big names
cuz it's usually like 70 bucks for a
pencil sketch like with the bigger names
whereas I I paid I paid 45 for a full
watercolor you know with with somebody
who is a lesser name and that like yes I
will take that and the last one let me
see if I can get these guys cards there
was a there's a pair of them that did
this one of them did the penciling
together did the inking and the the
coloring that's just that's just for
their twitch stream so I'm not entirely
sure what their actual names are but
apparently they're this is their twitch
stream but the guys that for the piece
I'm about to show you so if anybody
wants to watch them on that but you've
got ya got it completely screwed this up
hang on yeah
so what we've got for the last one
ha we have dark willow from Buffy I was
quite happy with that one too I'm happy
with all these I've yet to be unhappy
with with the commissioned piece and
it's one of the reasons I keep doing it
me and it like I almost never buy prints
I think I bought a print once and that
was the very first no that was the
second con I ever went to I bought a
print cuz I really didn't like it but
like theoretically anybody could buy the
prints i KY I get a commission and I
come away with something that only I
have I love that can you recall any
recurring dreams or nightmares from when
you were younger um not like in detail I
can tell you that the most the the
recurring things that would happen in
Nightmare feels like an overstatement
but like dreams I didn't enjoy would be
things like trying to run and feeling
like my legs were stuck in mud or
throwing a punch at somebody and having
it land and feeling like I hit with the
force of a marshmallow like that's
something that would happen to me a lot
in in dreams when I was younger still
does on occasion though not as much
those were big recurring sort of things
for me
who wouldn't the fight between Hades and
Maleficent oh that's a good question I
thought I suppose it depends on the who
has the home-field advantage whether we
are on the earthly plane or the
underworld
welcome back just join welcome Donna
looks like you had a blast at the
convention loved your Darth cosplay so
much yeah
so that witch that's the other thing I
hadn't mentioned last day
at the at the con hold on I think we've
got all right I'm keeping an eye out on
the chat I think somebody who's trolled
me before is back under a different name
just keep an eye on it ah so last day of
the con as far as cosplay goes I did I
got my sip gear out and I did but Dartz
snow is is what I call the the character
I mean it's my third time doing that one
in the third makeup variant I've done
the makeup different all three times
have done that and Liz did lieutenant
conics from the last Jedi which is the
character that Carrie Fisher's daughter
played so that that was that was always
that's always gonna be very sweet oh
yeah
hang on I got a GG deal boom there we go
sorry I'm gonna repeat troll who like
shows up with the same things over and
over and I don't know why they think
it's cute because it's literally the
exact same trolling scheme every single
time like you can't even think of
something new I don't know Doctor Who
for Star Wars equals mr. set so we've
run over a little bit oh I need to hop
over the disk or cuz I'm elected those
yet um
and I need to do that so
oh okay so over on the discord I had the
question what would your favorite
cosplay is that you saw there were a lot
of very cool cosplays um there were
there were a lot of Deadpool's there
were a number of
what I've come to think of as the
Lebowski Thor's the Thor from from
endgame there were a couple of those
there was a there was a Mary Marvel that
I really liked that was uh there was a
gwenpool excuse me there was a serpent
or from GI Joe which is the show I never
watched but I recognized the character
and the the fabrication work on the
armor was incredible there was a there
was a Vampirella that I am shocked they
let her walk the the con floor wearing
as little as she did but I think like
the one that bowled me over was the one
that ultimately won the costume contest
which was the last thing we saw before
we did the drive back up north so there
was a young woman I don't know how old
she was cuz I didn't sear you couldn't
see her inside this thing but she did
and I'm get I'm guesstimating at some of
these um dimensions but well I'm
guesstimating at the size the weight I
know cuz she said it was about a 12 foot
tall 60 pound screen accurate Iron Giant
and it moved she couldn't walk she could
move the arms the eyes were lit up it
was insane and she won the costume
contest which she deserved - hands down
it was it was preposterous that thing
and like they asked her how long it took
and then what you think once they to get
to hear her answers they had to hand
this mic sort of up and into the chest
cavity so she could hold it and she said
it took her five hundred hours and I
believe it it was crazy this thing so
I'm gonna kind of burn through the the
discord questions did John Barrowman
I mention that sadly he didn't his voice
wasn't up to it John Barrowman is lovely
in real life his heels on screen yes he
is how did your cosplays go over did
they work out well four whole days where
yes in all three cases and actually I
feel I feel really bad
Liz's feet hurt after that first day cuz
there was a slight heel in her boots
doing Supergirl none of my costumes had
heels I that was deliberate um when I'm
gonna be on the one up on the floor all
day long I'm not gonna do it doing it
he'll so yeah it was quite comfortable
uh would you say that the way you're
talking YouTube videos is the same way
you talk in real life yeah pretty much
that's I don't the only difference is I
swear more day-to-day that I do in
YouTube that's about it what is your
favorite Doctor Who cosplay or go to
Doctor Who cosplay for me personally I
still really like 13s outfit it's
comfortable it's colorful I love the
coat for something that I saw there was
what actually there was like this little
group that did a number of Doctor Who
cosplays when I was there first day and
I actually I actually got a picture with
him doing the 12th doctor well I was the
13th we got a picture together that was
cool and then the next day he did Davros
like very accurate and in the chair that
and it moved he could drive the chair
around and he had a Dalek with him and I
saw the Dalek parallel park like it came
in for the for the Doctor Who panel and
is like to get next up near the wall I
was funny um I'm just gonna burn through
these real quick so I can be in a
position to to wrap things up who was
your favorite interaction at the
convention um honestly was probably
night mage who was one of the cosplayers
I mentioned because you know I saw him
all three days and like by the third day
we were just we were just talking and
sort of sharing our geek times a little
bit he's very laid-back guy he's
really good cosplayer so like I and it I
can be weird said like I'm not like I at
least I don't think I come across as
weird but oh my first interactions with
people feel awkward to me I don't know
how awkward they come across but like
second third times I run into somebody
then I'm settled into a comforter
hopefully and I very much did with night
mage so I think he was probably my
favorite in terms of interacting with
him did John Barrowman know who you were
no no he didn't
how many famous people have you met like
properly met it's probably just
Barrowman and and Tim Curry I've had
live like spotted and or bumped into by
accident
people like Denis Leary and oh my god
what did I what did I just lose his name
huh ah I bumped into him in New York at
a Whole Foods and now I've completely
lost his name uh hang on give me one
second I'm not I'm not gonna be that
person who starts rambling off movies
and expecting people to guess so
hold on this is embarrassing Billy
Connolly there we go literally bumped
into Billy Connolly at a Whole Foods
what wasn't entirely sure it was him
until I heard him talk and I heard the
accent all right you met Tim Kurt yeah I
met Tim Curry at Boston Comic Con about
a year ago now which was great
could a light saber block a Harry Potter
charm depends on the charm because some
charms actually seem to shoot out bolts
of stuff I'm pretty sure I like
temperature block that but some of them
just have an effect on things like to
make it levitate or to knock it back and
a lightsaber might not do anything with
that so it depends on what the charm is
I recommend you watch the 1960 edition
of world enough and
it's bad lighting camera quality audio
the cliffhangers are like 60s whoo -
it's so cool and even more creepy I'm
not entirely sure what you talking about
there J excuse me I'm going to Boston
comic-con in a few days
Boston Boston is pretty cool sorry hang
on and got a deal with somebody here I
don't know why they they feel I need to
do this but you know I'm not gonna talk
about it am I gonna give him the
platform um
Boston besides III went to Boston as my
as my second comm that I ever went to
and and I enjoyed it I actually didn't
plan to go back because it's oh it's a
little too big for my taste
um like cuz when things get to a certain
size it's it's just overwhelming a bit
um but I went back a second time
specifically to get to meet Tim Curry
and it was worth it 100% that was that
was an amazing experience
met Ralph Macchio and Mario Cantone I
know that name but why can't I place it
I know that name Mario Cantone white guy
we've drawn a blank and I can't place it
right now lost track of how many people
I've met ha ha uh he's a comedian oh
okay Oh Thank You Carolyn Thank You Gabe
cool um I think oh he makes me gonna
wrap up soon I'm trying to give there
was anything else I wanted to mention um
from the con
any advance advice for going to cons for
the first time well um the the first
thing is if you're if you're going one
day or if you're going full weekend like
going for a weekend is it's kind of a
nice thing because the opening day the
it's usually a Friday it's always gonna
be these you today so you can like ease
into it as an experience before it gets
flooded with people
the Saturday and Sunday if you're gonna
be going in any kind of costume do not
sweat about how accurate it is or
whether you made it yourself or bought
it off the store rack just do it because
you want to and people will dig it and
if they don't they won't say anything
something like it's a very positive vibe
in a con so no one's gonna disparage you
so if you had parties like I don't know
if I wanna cause but yes you do ever
even wondering that the answer is yes
yes you do if you're going multiple days
don't spend money on day one unless it's
like a scenario where you're like
flipping through comics in a long box or
something and you come across like a
one-in-a-million oh my god I can't
believe they have this situation don't
spend your money on day one spend your
first day walking around and get a sense
of everything get a sense of the booths
the artists all the stuff that's
available to you sleep on it come back
start spending money the next day
because if you start really going with
your your initial shopping instincts you
were gonna spend way more than you
intended to would you might end up doing
anyways but it's what I do to try and
combat that a little bit all masters
have tried to control in different ways
but Missy didn't try to control 12 she
gave him a choice I can't imagine any
other master giving up cyber army no she
no she was trying to control him she
gate the reason she gave him that choice
is because she was certain she knew what
he would do in that situation if she
didn't think she knew what he was going
to do she would not have given him that
choice now she still had an escape plan
if things went south because what kind
of evil genius doesn't have an escape
plan but no she was still absolutely
trying to control him and when she
couldn't I think you get a little bit
less of that later on because I think
that kind of shook her faith in what it
was she was even doing and you get the
dynamic that we get
which personally I really love Michelle
Obama visited my high school when I was
a sophomore very cool Bernie Sanders
came to my high school when I was I
don't know what year it was I was there
but like if you live in Vermont if
you've lived in Vermont for more than a
year odds are you've probably met Bernie
Sanders at some point and I'm not even
exaggerating I think literally everyone
in the state has met Bernie I met George
Carlin and Eddie Izzard oh I can't
really say I've met Eddie Izzard I've
seen him perform live a few times and he
answered a question I had at a Q&A but I
haven't like gotten to go up we go hey
nice to meet you my name you know I
haven't haven't done any of that HR
Giger oh man that must have been
something although I'm not a fan of
Missy I would agree with you about the
controlling yet friendship type Missy
and Capaldi has this is extremely
obvious in the sea Devils - yeah it's
kind of along the same lines did he put
his hands up that's a question about
Bernie I can't remember now cuz like
that this was high school you know what
next year is my 20th high school reunion
ha crap I'm out of water
uh I have to meet Stanley and he called
me here oh highlight of my life like
here's the one other Stanley's story
that and I really do need to wrap it up
soon but here's the one other Stanley
tidbit I will I will give you from from
the Chris Claremont panel he talked and
Chris Claremont talked about coming to
the reunion that's Steve and Robyn Liz
does actually want to see if we can get
those sailor costumes and next time we
go to a con together Goa Stephen Robin
we'll see if that actually happens
but anyway so Chris Claremont was
talking about how he started in writing
because initially he was well he was
what at the at the time was a gopher
over at Marvel which nowadays they call
in an intern but back then they called
it go for you know good go for cut go
for coffee go for more ain't for the
printer go for this go for that and he
was he was looking over something that
he didn't fully identify the writer he
said Roy so I think him in the timeline
he's talking about Roy Thomas but I
won't swear to that but anyway he he
found something that was an
inconsistency with a Nick Fury
we're like because Chris Claremont had
read these these things before he knew
that years ago it had been established
that Nick Fury was an orphan and he's
reading this newer issue that's gonna go
to print soon and it has Nick Fury going
back to see his alive mother and like
hang out with his family and he goes to
Roy Thomas he says I found this this
issue and and and Roy said to him okay
we'll call Stan would you found the
problem you tell him and so Chris
Claremont got on the phone to call up to
the head office and he said that he goes
and I hear
hello true believer and he said yes he
did actually answer the phone like that
and that he pointed this out to Stan
Stan just went okay fix it and Chris
gonna fix it yeah fix it click and he
goes back to Roy and says uh
Stan said to fix it and where I said
okay so you fix it he's like but I'm
just no he told you to fix it you fix it
and Chris Claremont when the back and
sit down and racked his brain Fuhrman
okay let's just seems a little bit of
dog to establish that this is his
adoptive mother and his adoptive family
he's going back to see and Roy was like
cool great so we'll do that and that was
how he started writing ahead at Marvel
was basically through being tasked with
fixing an error that he found and like
he himself admitted that that this story
was slightly embellished over time but
man it was a great story Stan Lee died
on my birthday oh that's a bummer
favorite Doctor Who guest star oh geez I
mean are we allowed to count Tom Baker
as a guest start because I'm something
like his 1 seen as the curator Oh Oh
still love it
how many Daleks would it take to defeat
Thanos it wouldn't well it depends does
he have the Infinity Gauntlet or not cuz
if he does it doesn't matter how many
cuz they wouldn't fall on explosive new
who were generations
please stop like why why is the turn is
blowing up with their generations I've
really come to hate that it's stupid and
pointless I don't get it
we would defeat Thanos with only one
Dalek nicely done how many dogs would it
take to screw in a light bulb I don't
know how many would it take to stack to
reach the ceiling are you doing the
review procedure see Siegen
Legion season three has it started yet
did I miss that I'm juggling so much
stuff
I am losing track of things um call that
a maybe I mean I'm definitely gonna
watch it but the the thing is that I
when I did reviews of it previously they
were not particularly well viewed and
like I try not to have what I think the
the clicks are gonna be determine what I
do or don't do but you know when it's
something that's like gonna be a
commitment cuz like if I start reviewing
this show I'm gonna want to keep
reviewing it and so like that's
commitment to cover a whole thing like
maybe I'll do a season overview at the
end but even that it's kind of iffy
because like I've committed myself to
only doing four videos a week and so you
know with something like that I'm
bumping other stuff to do like a video
so mailing Legion and if I if I II feel
very strongly that it's gonna barely
crack a thousand views if I'm lucky I'm
like do I really want to sink a ton of
time into that because it's like it's
discerning sometimes sometimes what you
spend the most time on doesn't get a lot
of review doesn't get a lot of views
doesn't get a lot of traction right
cowboy bebop review took me forever
forever not a lot of traction on it so
you know I'll probably watch it but
reviews unlikely would you do anything
with the information of the nerd if he
asked absolutely I'm not sure I have
anything to propose to him because in
terms of like things like Buffy and an
angel I mean he's just covering it at a
at a more in-depth level than I ever
have so I don't know I feel like he'd be
slumming it coming on my channel to talk
about stuff like that and I'd be like
I'd be gay I like what he does a lot I'd
be absolutely game for it but I mean I
don't know
hey you know Pez the troll Slayer of
council of geeks I do my best
have you been started into an over
mourning house yeah Wampus I get what
you mean about Missy maybe I just prefer
masters having ambition that goes beyond
the doctor cuz I'm a little tired of new
who making him the most important thing
ever um I get that in generally speaking
I agree except that given the obsessive
nature of the master I don't have a
problem with the doctor being the most
important thing to the master I do have
a problem with the darker being the most
important thing like in the universe
ever so I'm we're on the same page there
would you be interested in seeing lost
classic episodes remade using the guy
from twice upon a time and other
look-alike actors no no I would not
because for most of the Lost episodes we
do have audio recordings that I would
much rather they do the animated
recreations I'm like are there any
stories that we don't even have that
for I'm pretty sure we've got at least
audio for all of them
somebody correct me if I'm wrong I'm
sure I am I'm I'm usually wrong thank
you very much Jay I appreciate that I
love to see Shira characters and
Hogwarts houses I don't know if that'll
be a video but that is a conversation
that Liz and I have had the thing is
that the the the Shiar characters they
they fit very cleanly for the most part
you know
[Music]
Scorpia is very helpful catcher is super
Slytherin as is shadow Weaver and
trapped it is incredibly ravenclaw
actually the one that we came to we
actually think glimmers a bit of a
Slytherin bow kind of wavers between
Ravenclaw and Hufflepuff adores a
Gryffindor you know and then there
aren't a ton of curve balls is Shira and
I think that's that's kind of the nature
of entertainment kind of more aimed at
had kids and that's not to say these
aren't complicated characters they're
wonderfully complicated but they do all
kind of you know where they're where
their characterization on their sleeve
what you see is what they are and that
to them again that doesn't make them
uncomplicated but it does kind of make
them unlaid in terms of you have to peel
something back to get to the real
character underneath they are kind of
just what you see of them which i think
and i think fits for kids entertainment
but it doesn't mean that doing something
like sorting them into Hogwarts houses
becomes pretty blindingly obvious for
most of them this is still here yeah I
have run long this time ah geez I gotta
go yeah I really gotta gotta wrap it up
- I put Bo and Gryffindor no no I think
I think Bo I think Bo is the Hufflepuff
array raised by um Ravenclaw's gotta go
to bed remember the universe is a
hologram life is as an illusion by gold
by did you like the Aquaman movie yeah
it was fun just got here have I missed
much
ah we're wrapping up then so just that
I'm supposed to go to California in
September I might get a tutorial of
Warner Brothers well enjoy you're gonna
watch the Lindsey Ellis vid coming soon
I don't know what she doing but I like i
watch all her stuff she's I'm assuming
it's gonna be part two of her game of
Thrones thing which I'm looking for
or two I went to Alaska and it was hot
Alaska's on fire at the moment or at
least it was as of like a week ago so
yeah all right
oh yeah I am gonna I am gonna wrap it up
so thanks everybody for tuning in the
con was amazing
I had a I had an absolute wonderful time
and I'll say it again I could not have
been able to do it without the support
that I get and like I cited the patreon
specifically because that's obviously
the most clearly quantified but like all
the support the views the comments the
super chats which are always appreciated
you're recommending the show to other
people if this channel and all its
ancillary stuff the patreon and
everything else wasn't the size that it
is I wouldn't have got I wouldn't have
been able to go to this con and I
wouldn't be going to Gallifrey 1 in
February but I get to do these things
because you folks are awesome and and
we're gonna wrap it up there so I want
y'all to remember you're beautiful you
are valid you are loved you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings and
showing off swag from cons every now and
again have a good night